oh my god we're watching West rural but
if you haven't finished the episode
please pause right now and then come
back there are spoilers ahead pause it
in the back
[Music]
hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where us GameSpot nerds get together
with you to talk about the things that
we like and today we're talking about
Westworld season finale which if you
didn't watch please watch it and then
come tuned in we told you there were
spoilers ahead and there are all right
guys the season was crazy and I want you
guys to sum up the season in one
sentence without using the words West
world robot or host and you can't say
any character names okay so uh okay guys
ready so we're not doing it together
we're not one at a time go ahead buddy -
scientists attempt to create artificial
cognition by using cyborgs in amusement
park setting as a big social experiment
this is a run-on sentence there you go
I'm gonna go a little bit more succinct
with mine yeah a madman's work of art
lives on forever
interesting that was beautiful that was
simple about the freakin episode you
know the season no no no those beautiful
me about the scene oh that was actually
really all right you're not getting out
of this one no I'm not
what makes humanity any different from
artificial intelligence I'm like friggin
that's I'm thinking boxwoods so this
this episode in particular was called
the bicameral mind so we have another
right now oh great more games yes we're
game so this game we're going to guess
what bicameral mind means so coming up
we can going backwards we can go
backwards this time yeah I'm gonna
explain though what because I realized
that we didn't look up no none of us
looked up what bicameral mind means
which is normally what we do when we're
researching doing the script of an
episode because sometimes it's all we
have this time I looked we looked up
after we watch the episode anybody like
anybody know what bicameral mind means
things you should have looked up before
and you should hook them so they're just
hiked for the finale you're taking it
first sure
well bias to camera'll kind of like a
view so the your mind is viewing two
things at once and I'm thinking it's
because of Dolores I don't know I like
that's it yeah I like that obviously -
there may be two portions of your mind I
think one has to do with listening to a
voice and the other has to do with an
action so one part of your brain our
consciousness tells the other part what
to do all right but it can I want to
combine both of their answers that's
fine go ahead to the cam vision the
auditory portion right yes bicameral
work with cameras sure two cameras two
hemispheres I have the answer right here
talking amongst each other so
bicameralism the philosophy of two
chambered miss so is a hypothesis in
psychology that argues that the human
mind once assumed a state in which
cognitive functions were divided between
one part of the brain which appears to
be speaking and a second part which
listens and obeys bicameral mind
yeah yeah oh good we're so good at this
we're so good at this all right so let's
say had no idea what was it going on
yeah let's talk about all the theories
that we had leading up to this finale
and whether they were true or not right
theory number one William is the man in
black and don't call me Billy confirmed
confirmed everyone yeah yes let's talk
about this so it was pretty obvious I
was waiting for like that obvious reveal
where it's just like oh they're the same
person but yeah they she's talking to
Dolores is talking to the man in black
and he's like oh yeah I knew William and
he gives us a whole backstory and then
William picks up a black hat and then
they show the merge from old William to
new William so the knife they're done
all that stuff by the time that Dolores
is you know what's her name Evan Rachel
original wood yeah by the time the
twitchy face happens oh you're like oh
come on we already do yeah we're you we
thought they would reveal it earlier and
it was yes yeah we knew this all right
theory number two
Arnold still alive
[Music]
Arnold he's dead yeah well he's a pretty
[ __ ] prolific coder for a dead guy
whoa not really kind of Bernard says
that he's been fighting forward he's
still fighting forward but we don't have
any concrete proof that worlds
consciousness has been uploaded into
anyone or anything like that I feel like
a couple of times in this episode this
time included they gave all the
theorists they're little moment in the
Sun and then fighting you yeah
all right theory number three Ford's new
narrative is the maze
[Music]
so kind of yeah pretty much so we
thought that Bryan you have an exploit
yeah we thought that that the maze was
eventually gonna try to trap the hosts
but yeah he had this whole thing planned
out and we kind of thoughts before the
he that even them awakening Maeve's
whole what she thought was her own
choices it actually turns out that was
all part of his new narrative and that
he had it all planned out so it's not a
it's not a game for for for any of the
people that are that are visiting but it
wasn't a trap either he knew what they
were doing yep indeed they're doing they
know what they're doing theory number
four Dolores is Wyatt and killed Arnold
[Music]
yep
yeah and yep literally what's funny is
we thought that they were placed her in
somebody's memory like as Wyatt she
literally had Wyatt uploaded into her
brain yeah that is so easy yeah
what did it say exactly said Wyatt
narrative right being uploaded there it
is literally is Wyatt and we saw Raquel
Arnold yep and next theory forward is a
host I don't know what I would find
if I open you up I mean there's always
next season yeah I mean yeah who knows
someone might show up with that little
zippy thingy the cure-all just like
fixes him right in the head
humans as well
it's a magical tool from the future that
just fix all your future next theory
West world is not a physical place
[Music]
where are we we don't know we don't know
still don't know I mean we're not
looking so bright we're not sure I do
too but I'm willing I'm willing enough
to leave it open because if they don't
if the what the moment that was bleeped
enough right I believe a self censored
in next season or season 3 because you
know there's gonna be three seasons it
was amazing it's like this was all a
joke
yeah unplug it that that that men in
black marble moment yes yes all right
and final Theory Maeve makes it out of
West world
[Music]
no she's still there she got so close
she got on the train we never saw the
train leave so we don't know what would
actually happen if she had stayed on the
train but she got off the train she saw
the little girl and then she decided to
stay yeah she was broke in our program
right the storyline was written so yeah
escaping was part of her some part of it
but not getting all the way out yeah all
right the tease yeah I wonder where
she's going
I wonder indeed we have a theory from
Matt something a viewer submitted a
theory and said that the hosts are
repairing themselves and that's how we
got the Minotaur yeah so they're just
taking parts from animals and other
hosts I thought that theory was so
awesome that's why there's like
like-minded like like why it's mannered
all weird yeah saw the messing with
different parts and stuff so I mean yeah
but no pop no proof was actually shown
so I'm not sure yeah it's a good theory
though like we haven't actually seen
whether or not this is true all right
let's go into nerd chills so let's pick
our nerd chills moments for this episode
which moment really resonated with you
the most but it would start with you so
after we get through that stupid hallway
of just like humping hosts I was like
why do they have the host on just having
sex all night not that it's not a cool
hallway but someone needs to save the
power or at least come through with some
wd-40 or something this is crazy we get
through that moment and I'm like silly
plot hole then this awesome like
what's-her-name arms the tattoo boobs is
like hiding by other naked hosts and
just has this terrifying smile on her
face and then just wreaks havoc with
everybody that moment was awesome yeah
we were just awakening and it's like yes
moment I lasted 10 minutes just 10
minutes of gore that whole sequence very
good sequence Ryan yeah I loved during
that whole sequence and then the
fact that we go through a another
section of the underground then you see
like the samurai world yeah you see
another West world logo yeah who knows
how many of these worlds are there are
out there you know it's it's just
awesome to kind of have that curtain
pulled back and see more of what is out
there and what they've created yeah yeah
and yeah Felix gives her gives made that
paper it says what sickle Park one one
yeah so out of how many
we don't know setting up for future
seasons all right mine was when we see
that cold storage is completely empty
and then it goes back to the park and
then ghost nation starts appearing or
just coming out of the woods and the man
in black and the man miles and that was
a great party smiles
we call them bill bill hey Bill yep
so our question of the week comes from
youtube user black love who says what or
how many timelines are we seeing in each
episode past present future or
alternative we're thinking three right
especially to be seen of the season you
you have dolores stab wound dolores not
stab wound dolores blue dress yes so i
think those are three different i think
earlier in the season we've seen moments
moments but i mean it's impossible to
say how many different times you jump to
because it's all one timeline and i know
we've said different timelines like
they're in different universes or
something but we didn't mean that i
think that we watch the show and we see
different times it's like this happened
in this time and this time this year and
this time so the williams stuff yeah
and then yeah the man in black and but
also dolores figuring everything out so
yeah we're gonna say three all right
let's also shout out to you toxic to go
on youtube who was hoping this episode
for the finale would be longer than 10
minutes so here you go i hope you're
happy
thank you so much for watching the show
so let's jump into
predictions finally for season two we
don't know when we're getting season two
it could be awhile from now but what do
you think will happen in season two I
think that guys think think about this
we saw that host that Ford was creating
yes we don't know who was still so what
if at the end there that was Ford's host
himself yeah or it is a house for it is
the point so actually you're you're
right or it is a host and he's still
alive and he sent his host out there to
share them there that's my boy that's my
boy right why would he want to sacrifice
himself he's still in control of the
whole thing he's totally fine you're
right
cuz why else would we see that host down
there and not see it ever again
they they wanted us to see that numerous
times it was a pretty obvious yeah I
think he was creating his host put him
in a nice tux and sent him out there and
revealed the whole thing so he's still
out there I think season two I think
Hopkins coming back yeah no that's a
really good post maybe blow my mind dude
yeah yours was way better thought out
than mine but mine that Ford was a host
and you didn't actually die right then
was sort of kind of what I had okay or
he did kill himself and then have has
Bernard he was like hey partner I'm here
and Bernards like dude are you a are you
a human and he's like no I'm a host just
like do you do let's do this thing
like then they're they're like Bonnie
and Clyde in it or someone losing it or
you know I guess another cinematic duo
that's cute yes how about you uh well we
saw Dolores taken out a bunch of humans
at the end of that we assume issues like
wiping out the board so the with the
board dead what happens now I think that
the hosts are going to try to escape but
I don't know what it is Williams not
dead right I mean know what about him he
could easily get killed in the next two
minutes it's true I mean smiles but
maybe he fights his way out he kills all
all of ghosts nation I don't think he's
an old man who gets you know who's
gotten punched in the face by robots
that's true
robot punches often you know like though
he spent so much time in the park you
should know what to do in the situation
it's like an emergency I think I think
we smile signified that he was totally
fine with him dying in that moment
that's what I got most baller and I
could have gotten thank you I couldn't
dilation of ghost nation so one thing I
do want to say that doesn't have to do
with predictions or whatever yeah
there's bells on the gravestones there
are and they used to do this thing have
you ever heard of dead ringer so dead
ringer is a term that you you'd say like
oh you're a devil someone else yeah so
you'd bury somebody but before modern
medicine you wouldn't know if they were
actually dead so sometimes people would
like wake up from like poisoning or like
a coma or whatever buried in a coffin so
you would tie a bell to their finger and
hang it over their their marker and they
would be ringing the bell so you'd hear
a grave Bell and go dig up a not dead
person Wow
that's why all of those but also dead
ringers so are they just gonna duplicate
all those board members and just make
him into hoes I think it's so I think
that whole thing was another loop like I
think the board has been cleared out
before by Ford on accident happened to
get yeah on accident yeah he's dealt
with them numerous times because that
was that that ending was a loop we
talked about that but that ending was a
loop of what Delores already did she
killed a ton of people and then ended up
killing one of her creators yep it's a
Ford still alive for life yeah I really
like that
I really like that that's rad dude all
right guys so West world is over and we
need to fill the void that it left with
a new
so what show do you want to nerd out
with us over please let us know in the
comments below or on twitter at the
hashtag gs nerding out we are moving
over permanently to GameSpot universe on
YouTube as of January 3rd so if you're
watching on GameSpot right now please go
over there and subscribe if you're on
GameSpot universe great job guys what
can they see on gamespot universe so we
do features all the time on like we just
did a bunch of Star Wars Theory stuff
you should go check that out character
breakdowns backstory stuff where that
kids a lot of who the heck is do you
want to know who the heck is somebody we
probably we have it or if not tell us to
do yeah tell us to do it oh and also
we're nerding out on to other shows
right now we've got Walking Dead and we
have agents of shield which I'm pretty
nerdy about but we have Tony G who's a
comic genius and I don't mean that in
the funny way oh alright well thank you
guys for joining us and for all things
nerding out stick with games